digamos que te dedicas al cuidado de
niños y que te gustaría tener un
registro de cuáles son los niños que
cuidas y digamos que el último mes
cuidaste a seis niños y anotas de todas
sus edades muy bien pero cuando regresas
a revisar tu registro ves una mancha de
tinta azul que se derramó sobre una de
las edades y olvidaste la edad de ese
niño así que primero tal vez te pongas
nervioso quizás te preocupes pero
después recuerdas que agregaste un dato
más la media aunque ya agregaste la
media o que también se le conoce como
promedio y eso lo añadís te 'la cuando
cuando hayan montaste la última de las
edades verdad y digamos entonces que la
media vale 4 que ya sí que dado que
sabes cuál es la media y 5 de las edades
el reto es deducir cuál es esta edad
faltante y como siempre te invito a que
hagas una pausa trates de resolver este
problema por tu cuenta y después lo
hacemos juntos
así que suponiendo que ya te diste
tiempo para meditar este problema vamos
a hacerlo y lo primero que tenemos que
hacer es recordar cómo se calcula la
media ok entonces para calcular la media
recordemos que hay que primero calcular
la edad total verdad o bueno la suma de
todas las edades entonces vamos a llamar
a eso el total de las edades que el
total de las edades y después eso hay
que dividirlo entre el número de datos o
el número de edad es verdad que son 6
son 5 aquí y una desconocida entonces
vamos a ponerle número de edades muy
bien entonces ahí lo tenemos esta es la
forma en la que se calcula la media o
que también se le conoce como el
promedio verdad entonces una forma
también de resolver este problema es
multiplicar de ambos lados de esta
igualdad por el número de edades
entonces
y multiplicar de ambos lados por el
número de edades muy bien ahí lo tienen
de un lado y luego multiplicamos
multiplicamos por el número de edades
también del lado derecho entonces lo que
logramos con esto es que este número se
cancela con este número verdad y del
lado izquierdo sólo nos queda el total
de las edades que ya sólo lo voy a
escribir como total debería ser igual a
lo que tenemos del lado derecho que es
la media multiplicada por el número de
edades muy bien así es como podríamos
tratar de resolver este problema ya lo
mejor esto está muy abstracto vamos a
hacerlo con numeritos para que sea mucho
más fácil entonces como calculamos el
total de las edades bueno pues habría
que sumar todas verdad entonces tenemos
5 más 2 más un número que no conocemos
verdad y que lo estamos poniendo como
signo de interrogación
las dos más 48 muy bien ahí está el
total de las edades y esto hay que
dividirlo entre el número de edades que
sabemos que son 1 2 3 4 5 6 verdad son 6
porque además tenemos uno desconocido
muy bien y esto debe ser igual a la
media pero la media sabíamos que valía 4
muy bien entonces como lo hicimos en el
paso anterior podríamos multiplicar de
ambos lados por el número de edades pero
bueno vamos a simplificar antes todo
esto cuánto es por ejemplo 5 más 2 esto
vale 7 verdad y cuánto es 2 más 48 es 2
+ 4 son 6 y 8 son 14 son 14 entonces si
ahora sumamos 7 y 14 eso nos da 21
verdad y ahora sí podríamos multiplicar
de ambos lados por el número de edades
que son 6
del lado izquierdo por supuesto que se
cancelan y del lado derecho pues
podríamos hacer la operación así que a
final de cuentas que es lo que con lo
que nos quedamos tenemos el 21 más
nuestro número desconocido verdad lo
demás ya lo simplificamos y del lado
derecho tenemos 4 por 6 verdad 6 por 4
es lo mismo entonces vamos a notar eso
tenemos 21 más
signo de interrogación que es lo que no
sabemos eso nos debe dar 4 por 6 que son
24 ok
corregir eso
ahí está vamos a escribir que son 24 muy
bien entonces como podríamos obtener el
valor del signo de interrogación bueno
podríamos restar 21 de ambos lados
verdad y entonces lo que nos queda son
24 menos 21 que también podríamos pensar
que el número hay que sumarle a 21 para
que nos dé 24 y eso por supuesto tiene
una respuesta y eso vale 3 verdad
24 - 21 vale 3 o bien sea 3 o sea 21 le
sumamos 3 nos da 24 entonces ya pudimos
obtener la edad desconocida verdad con
toda esta información que teníamos la
sin cuidades y el promedio pudimos
hallar la edad faltante pudimos ver que
detrás de la tinta había un número 3 no
sé ustedes pero a mí me parece esto muy
emocionante